[Music]
I've been following this Anthony weaner
story pretty closely
I've been following Weiner very closely
and it's gotten me got me very upset I'm
upset not because Weiner is a creep but
because all the attention he's getting
is a clear case of
East Coast media bias well I'm out here
on the west coast see and we've got
we've got a much better sex scandal
going on right now but it's being
completely ignored because we're on the
west coast I'm talking about San Diego
mayor Robert Filner
yes he's a much bigger creep but he's
west coast and everybody's talking about
the East Coast green and I'm sick of it
we growing creepy out here too yeah
well don't just take my word for it
let's put them up side by side you
decide for yourself in our first East
Coast West Coast municipal government
perv off here we go Anthony Weiner
texted pictures of his penis two women
had never actually met Bob Filner this
is true not only met the women he
allegedly waited until they were trapped
in an elevator and then put them in a
headlock yes that's a point for Phil
there uncalibrated the number of women
who've come forward about ethany weiners
sexting so far to to the number of women
who come out forward about Filner eight
eight
[Music]
Anthony Weiner's name is Weiner Filner's
name is okay let's just give that one to
Weiner Weiner guess that one Anthony
Weiner is 48 years old
Robert Filner is 70 he's been seriously
creeping women out since the late 1950s
that's despite his sex scandal Anthony
Weiner is not dropping out of the race
that's kind of creepy Bob Filner is not
only staying in office he's demanding
the city pay for his legal defense
Filner wins again Anthony Weiner's
online nickname is Carlos danger mayor
Filner's nickname we just found this out
Pedro slums work yes that's both Mexican
and British
finally this is the photograph anthony
Weiner's been sending everywhere that's
the photograph yeah but we got that beat
here's the official portrait of mayor
Filner
[Applause]
I don't even know what I'm doing right
now